this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 55. with Echo Charles EC yes and
me sitting here so uh I was on Sam
Harris's podcast like a lot but it seems
like a long time ago now and we we're
supposed to do another one at some point
but
we just haven't yet anyways on that
podcast
we had a discussion about bravery and
one of the things that he said which was
a quote for somebody else
I'm pretty sure
you can't fake bravery
you can't fake bravery so if there's a
if there's a gun fight and there's a guy
wounded in the street
and there's gunfire everywhere and you
run out to save that wounded guy and
drag him to safety
you're brave
you can't fake that now and it doesn't
actually it doesn't matter what you were
thinking at that moment in time it
doesn't matter if you were petrified and
horrified it doesn't matter if you were
just pushed out there by pure adrenaline
it doesn't matter if you had given up on
living you're like I don't care I'm
gonna die anyways I'm gonna go doesn't
matter
doesn't matter you knew there was danger
and you acted
and you can't fake that again it doesn't
matter what your thoughts were
you could have been like I want to get a
medal so I'm gonna wrap this you still
did a brave thing might have been for
the wrong reason but you were still
Brave that's true
you could have been petrified and like
you could have thought oh everyone's
gonna think I'm a wimp if I don't do
this I don't want to do it but I'm gonna
do it anyways you're still Brave
so you can't fake bravery in the same
idea applies to
a lot of other
qualities it doesn't matter what you
think or how you're thinking what
matters what you actually do that's what
matters
so discipline okay I talk about
discipline a lot
if you if the alarm clock goes off and
you get up and get out of bed doesn't
matter what you were thinking doesn't
matter that you wanted to sleep in it
doesn't matter they're like oh this
sucks none of that matters did you do it
did you get up and did you go
working out
I did squats today did you squats
yesterday you said uh no it's two days
ago three days ago I did not want to do
them did not
did hard jujitsu
hard Jiu Jitsu Saturday
not as hard but hard Jiu Jitsu Sunday
you know how you get the full body
soreness a little bit when you go hard
full body dumps full body Doms so but I
was like sore did not want to do squats
not at all
guess what
guess what did squats yeah
it doesn't matter that I didn't want to
do them doesn't matter that I uh
procrastinated yeah stretched did some
Mobility work for 13 minutes you don't
need 13 minutes worth of Mobility work
before no but I did it
got done with that guess what okay now
we're doing squats so it doesn't matter
what I was thinking that I didn't want
to do it that I was being a wimp inside
my own head because I did what I'm
supposed to do
what if you're in a leadership position
and you know you're supposed to put the
team first
and that's what you do um
that's what you do you put the team
first that's what you did as long as you
did it you did it now listen there's a
little caveat here that is that intent
has a smell yeah and if you put the team
first because you know it's gonna look
good it's going to make you look good
and that's why you did it everyone's
gonna smell that yeah
so there's a little caveat there but for
the most part
actions are more important than words
are
which is a weird thing to say because
everyone talks about
the importance of words and writing and
what you say right it's very important
but let's face it actions trumps those
things yeah
uh
then you get this weird I don't know you
know how this ties in but you think
about this thing where
you get someone that's short-term
will make it happen but long term they
don't make it happen example you ever
look you've seen plenty of Fighters come
through the victory MMA like Pro
Fighters amateur Fighters
you notice how some of them there's some
of those Fighters that would never give
up in a fight ever
but they will go they will literally
never give up in a fight but they won't
show up to practice for four days
you know what I'm saying like they're so
driven in the fight yeah on the short
term like they're there
but they but they missed three days of
practice or they didn't they didn't
adjust their diet now they're overweight
coming in they got to cut the extra see
what I'm saying yeah it's like a short
term versus long term yeah
SEAL training same things happens basic
SEAL training you get you get someone
that's just like not gonna quit and they
don't but they can't pass the run
because they didn't freaking train for
the four months six months year prior to
going to training they didn't have the
discipline to train for a long period of
time but in that moment you could never
make this dude quit
and by the way
sometimes you get someone that's in
outstanding condition
and they came to every practice
and then they get in the fight and they
they break I mean there's we know
Fighters have broken like professional
fighters both that we've known and that
we've watched
they break in the ring you watch them
break in the cage you can have
exceptionally trained athletes going to
basic SEAL training
they're incredible athletes they're
better at me in every category of
Athletics in every category running
swimming strength endurance they just
beat me in every category they quit um
that's kind of crazy right
so so that's this thing where both those
both those things don't win you you
gotta have that long-term and the short
term
discipline you gotta have the short term
and the long-term coverage you gotta
have the discipline to do something long
range but then you also got to protect
your neck
what do I mean by that is if you don't
protect your neck in on the mats you
lose yeah
you got sometimes you gotta go oh I
Gotta Give Up position I got to give up
you know all these other things in this
moment in time I gotta panic I gotta use
a bunch of energy but I gotta protect my
neck because if I don't protect my neck
it's over so well-trained Fighters
sometimes they quit well-prepared buds
trainees sometimes they quit
and all these things
are going back to
our actions
or actions and there's a saying about
this well it's sort of
let's say an adjacent saying sure which
I I guess you've heard before saying
watch your thoughts they become words
watch your words they become actions
have you ever heard this before some
people take it a little bit further even
so some people say watch your thoughts
they become words watch your words they
become action watch your actions they
become your character watch your
character for it becomes your destiny
quotes right and this is this this quote
has been attributed to different people
over time Emerson
Lao Tzu the the Chinese philosopher I
even saw one that gave the credit to
Margaret Thatcher's father
basically
it's a quote that seems to have evolved
over time and is in different many
different forms out there
but here's the thing people talk about
watch your thoughts because they come
words watch your words because they
become your action
watch your action because it becomes
your character watch your character
becomes a country destiny
here's what I'm going to say
watch your free watch your freaking
actions
watch your actions and here's why I'm
saying this because
you can see your actions you can track
your actions you can adjust your actions
they're quantifiable
your thoughts
no one can see them you you can you can
uh rationalize your thoughts you can
rationalize your words you can say
something but do something else
all those things can take place
but your actions are real
so what I'm saying is
watch your actions be conscious be aware
of what your actions are your actions
are what count when you go when you're
going through that little debate in your
mind like I was today when I was getting
ready to do squats
yeah when you're going through that
debate in your mind be like oh none of
the things that are in my mind right now
matter what matters is how I act right
now that's what matters that's what I
had to say to myself
I was like oh none of this that's going
through my mind right now matters at all
it's all just it's all just rubbish it's
junk what matters is I have to do what
I'm supposed to do
that's what we need to pay attention to
you can sit there and think about God
knows what
you can think about the rest day you
need you can think about the
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground